So using information from the pedigree here, we should have been able to discern
that Kate could have only possibly been
one genotype. The minus minus. You'll remember the
[UNKNOWN]
homozygous combination, which is the recessive trait. And
that her brother could be either heterozygous or
homozygous. For the dominant thymine, or positive, allele.
Now how do we come up with this?
Well, looking at our pedigree here, we know
that Kate is affected by the trait of
lactose intolerance. We know that the trait of
lactose intolerance is recessive. Meaning that there's only one
allelic combination the homozygous recessive combination that she
could be, she must be minus minus. Her
brother on the other hand we know is
unaffected. Well if he's unaffected that means he can't
be minus minus, there are two other possible
options. He could be homozygous plus plus or
heterozygous plus minus based on the information for
the pedigree alone. We can't determine which is which.